i'll give you three data sets and as you
can see just by looking at the numbers
it quite different data sets to each
other right but you've gone ahead you
calculated all their means now that i've
fixed this one
and um because each of them has the same
number of scores
and each of them has the same sum
overall they all add up to 70.
you get the same mean every single time
um
seven and seven and seven now it's not
immediately obvious the first time you
look at the numbers before you start
punching them into your calculator
that they're going to be this different
but let me show you a picture
which might help you understand what's
going on here we go
um now i know because of the color it's
a bit funky but hopefully you can squint
a little bit
and you can see in here this is our
first date which has like
five up to nine i think um this is one
with lots of
fours and lots of sort of tens elevens
and then you've got this guy which
clearly has that outlier there i think
it's like 55 or something like that
okay now i know the red bars are all in
different spots
the my bar for the average but they're
really different spots because of the
scale they are all equal to seven
so we're looking at measures of central
tension at the moment
and they don't tell the whole story they
don't tell the whole story which is
going to be our segue
into what we're learning today so let me
get this out of the way if you haven't
already
quite definitely if you haven't already
make this heading i know it's got a bit
of a gap in it
um mean was the first
measure of central tendency we looked at
mean
but we have two others right what are
they median very good
so this is like the the center about at
the middle of our data
and then you've got the most common
score right
so mean median and mode
they're good but they are not always
sufficient to try and give you a sense
of what is this group of people
like what is this um set of schools like
what's this population
can you give me an idea of its
characteristics
the mean the mode the median they'll
give you a um they'll give you some
information but
they don't always tell the whole story
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to let me get this out of the way
we're going to complement these with a
couple of different measures right
actually
three i'm going to tell you about two
today okay um the measures we're going
to look at
are and i hope you've heard of these
before so this will be a bit of revision
range which is the highest score
take away the lower score in fact i'll
even write that
the highest score take away the lowest
score so it's just that difference
that's the range of the scores and then
secondly
well actually i'm not going to tell you
what the second one is yet we'll get to
in a minute
now range is what we call not a measure
of central tendency like where's the
middle
range is what we call a measure of
spread that's our head
it tells you how spread out the data is
the bigger the range
the more spread out the data is that
makes sense the more spread out the
sores are
range is great if you have a think about
the three sets of data i gave you in the
beginning
you can look at them really quickly and
work out what the highest score and the
low score is for each one
what are the ranges for each set of
scores can you tell me what's the range
of the first
set of scores do you need the numbers
again do you want something
that's fine um the numbers are
here we go we can actually just do them
together just by glancing at things
here we go um if you have a look at
these numbers again it looks like the
smallest one is
five and the biggest one is nine so that
gives you a range of nine take away five
which is four okay good when you have a
look at this one again you've got
a lower score and a higher score so the
range here is
nine so i just dropped these down we
said four
and nine and what's this one
you go all the way from one up to 55 so
you've got a range
of 54 okay so these numbers
they clearly at a glance unlike the mean
they tell you immediately that there's a
difference between these right
it doesn't tell us all the things but it
does give us a good idea
right now what i want you to notice is
the range is helpful it gives us some
useful information
but it has a problem in fact has the
same problem
that the mean has because remember when
we talked about
each of these we talked about when you
use them and when you don't use them
what was the problem that the mean had
which the meaning and the mode can
fix what what sort of weakness did it
have yeah
very good if you've got numbers that are
kind of like outside the range
of all your normal numbers then they're
going to throw out your mean
okay and it's the same thing with the
range right it's still
it's still susceptible so this is worth
writing down because sometimes you have
to choose or justify why you choose this
or that it's still susceptible to
outliers
the way the mean is right so we've
solved one problem
of the me which is that you always get
you can only get
the one number so it doesn't tell you
the whole story but these
here they're not perfect either okay so
in addition to range
to try and get away from this outlier
problem we introduce
something a little more specific called
the interquartile range
who remembers this who's yeah ringing
bells excellent okay so
let me put this
so the interquartile range is very
similar to this high score take away
lower score
but what it introduces is these
quartiles i'll talk about them in a
second
it talks about rather than highest and
lowest it talks about an upper quartile
which is higher as the name suggests
and it's still a difference it's the
upper quartile takeaway anyone want to
guess
the lower quartile very good they're
trying not to make it too
groundbreaking now because it's a bit of
a mouthful to say upper quartile and
lower quartile all the time we give
these guys
labels they're quartiles we call them
q3 and q1
they go in order ascending order so the
lower quartile is the first one you
encounter so it's q1
q2 is right in the middle of the data we
actually have a name for that already
and it's on the board
it's the medium right smack bang in the
middle
and then as you keep on climbing up the
data you get to the third
and final quartile okay now
why are they called quartiles this is a
really important concept which um we
need to wrap a head zone because it'll
be
important tomorrow as well the reason
why they're called quartiles is because
each of these scores q1
q2 q3 they divide up your population or
your set of scores into
sections now do you remember what the
media does what do you remember i gave
you
you we had like an informal simple
definition and then i gave you like a
longer more awkward one do you remember
what that was
yeah no anyone
yeah very good so in other words the
median it divides you into two equal
halves
right that's what the median does you've
got like you know four
uh five scores down that way and five
scores up that way that's what q2 does
okay therefore the quartile row does is
instead of dividing
you into two equal sections because it's
a
quartile it divides you up into
four equal sections okay so maybe you
want to jot that down as your definition
of what a quartile
is it divides your scores
into four equal sections
okay so for instance if you knew what
q1 q2 and q3 were and you're like oh i
my score whatever i'm like you know my
height or my weight or my
income is above q3 that means you know
you're in the top 25 of the population
right
or alternatively you could say i'm in
the bottom 25 or whatever it might be
okay